i've been very blessed to have had some
absolutely amazing friendships in my
life
and while many of them have come and
gone some of them got married some of
them moved
town one of them became a priest
actually
but all the amazing friends in my life
have taught me something about what it
means to be
me because i think you view yourself
through the eyes
of other people especially people you're
close with so i think it's really
important to surround yourself
with the right people to form your tribe
with intention
you want to surround yourself with
people who make you a better person
and for the most part those types of
relationships are going to be
friendships but you don't get
quality friendships by following a
step-by-step action plan or something
like that some of the best relationships
i've ever had in my life seemed to have
just
randomly happened when i wasn't really
expecting it whatsoever
so needless to say with this video i'm
not interested in giving you a
step-by-step
guide as to how to make everyone want to
be your friend or anything like that
because i think that's kind of futile
and dumb but i do want to talk about
some really useful things that i've
learned throughout my life that have
really helped me make friends easier and
make higher quality friends
and overall just connect with people a
lot more genuinely
the number one tip that i have is to
always assume
initiative so back when i was like 15 or
16 years old i was browsing
reddit self-improvement forums and stuff
like that i was on like r
social skills and i came across this
post that pretty much
changed my entire life i've been looking
everywhere for this one post but i can't
find it anywhere so if someone can help
me out with this that'd be great but in
the post there was this guy who talked
about how
he didn't have very many friends and the
friends that he did have were starting
to fade away and he didn't know why
you know he's kind of a loner kind of an
introvert and all these friends started
to just drift away from him and he was
getting really upset
until the very last friend that he had
finally stopped calling him
angry confused and saddened by this this
reddit poster runs up to his friend and
says
dude where'd you go why'd you stop
calling me why don't you invite me to
stuff
anymore and his friend turned to him and
simply said
it's because you don't invite me
anywhere i i figured you didn't like
hanging out with me
and this really kind of changed my
perspective because
i just never invited people anywhere
i always waited for the invitation i was
always sitting there on my butt
wondering why nobody was inviting me to
cool parties and stuff
and i eventually realized that i wasn't
making any effort whatsoever to make
plans and call people up invite them to
stuff
you know if you don't have very many
friends and you tend to not do things
very often and you want to be someone
who does things with people
then take control just like any other
aspect of your life if you want to
change something it's up to you because
it's your life
so take control of your social life as
well always assume initiative if you
want to do something fun
come up with an idea invite the person
to that idea
if they don't want to come to that idea
leave them be
is that recording i recorded you peeing
did you
yeah okay so the next big thing that
i've learned is that honesty
is the antidote one of the biggest
pitfalls in any social interaction
is the fear of voicing your opinion or
being controversial or
politically incorrect or offensive but
this fear
really has to go if anybody is to know
who you are in this world
because so many people are so agreeable
they're extremely careful
about every little thing they say
they're making sure they're not hurting
anyone's feelings
they're making sure that they're
laughing at everyone's jokes they're
being very pleasant and what this
eventually does
is that you tend to be seen by a large
amount of people as
oh yeah he's he's nice you know like
people are kind of
they don't really know you but you're
unoffensive to them so you're okay to
have around
you'll be liked by everyone but loved by
no one so if you're the kind of person
who doesn't
ever want to make any sort of waves or
make anyone feel uncomfortable
and you find it really hard to make it
past kind of a surface level
acquaintanceship with most people then
that's probably the reason
by not voicing your true opinions by not
speaking honestly about
things that you're passionate about or
things that you've learned or
standing up for what's right you're
basically concealing your identity from
people
and people don't tend to bond with
people that they don't know at all
especially people who they don't trust i
feel like everybody has a few people in
their life
that when they come across them in a
grocery store or something like that you
have the exact same conversation every
single time hey man how's it going
oh yeah that's cool how's how's the
hockey team going
oh yeah sweet yeah so you getting on the
ice a lot
oh that's good man that's good man yeah
your wife's
you know family's all good that's good
that's good
well i'm gonna let you go i gotta get
running but uh great running into you
i'll see you some other time
you know i feel like i have that
conversation with like eight to ten
people in my life usually just like
people i play hockey with or something
like that so i'm not saying you need to
get past that stage with every single
person that you meet in this world and
form deep friendships with everybody you
lock eyes with but what i am saying
is that if you're interested in forming
deeper relationships with people
then you have to be willing to kind of
break out of that small talk
the small tech break out of that small
talk
ask questions you're actually curious
about and that you might think is like a
weird thing to ask
but if you want to ask it just get good
at just asking it
when you say something that's like
controversial and polarizing
people can do either two things they can
either really bond with what you're
saying and be like yeah man that's
awesome i totally agree or they can be
like
i'm out of here this guy's cracked and
both of those things are a really good
thing
because of my next point which is
rejection is a very useful tool
when you communicate honestly when you
wear your opinions on your sleeve when
you're not afraid to be controversial
and be who you are in front of other
people then you're inevitably going to
make a lot of people
run the other way because they
completely disagree with you
and that's a very good thing because you
can find out very quickly
who the people who are actually staying
are and the people who are staying are
probably people who you can
actually bond with and i was thinking
about this the other day because i think
rejection
is like an inevitable thing that always
happens
if people are incompatible and it can
either happen right away or it happens
very gradually over the course of a very
painful and toxic relationship a quick
rejection is one where one person starts
talking
and the other person starts talking you
know you don't vibe with that person
at all so you kind of go the other way
and you never talk with that person
again
that's an acute rejection you know from
a dating perspective
you know you walk up to a girl or a guy
or whoever you're approaching
and you're all like hey baby and then
they're they're like nah get out of here
you
you suck you smell your breath is bad i
i don't like you
and then that's it you're like okay that
kind of sucks but fair enough i should
probably brush my teeth
that's an acute rejection and you never
have to talk with that person again but
that's what happens when people are
being
honest they're saying what they mean one
person's like hey i'm interested
in bonding with you the other person's
like no go away
and then they split up i think that's
absolutely perfect
it's honest communication clear-cut
results
but a gradual rejection is something
that people don't really think about a
lot
and i think it's when two people are
incompatible but neither of them are
very good at communicating honestly
so these two types of people might
actually get into a friendship
or a relationship and then find out
later down the road that they
actually don't really like each other at
all and they resent tons of things about
them
so they start to become bitter at each
other and start to get mad at their
fundamental differences
start to get petty about little things
like you know if they leave a banana on
the table
and you lash out at them but you're not
really lashing out of the banana you're
lashing out of the fact that you
disagree
about religious and political things but
you never sorted out to begin with and
now you have to deal with all this like
drama later it's just an absolute mess
but usually that only happens
because two parties aren't really
communicating very honestly at the
beginning
they can't see the differences right off
the bat evaluate them and then realize
you know what this person's so much
different than me this is probably going
to cause a lot of pain and turmoil down
the road so i'm just gonna split before
it gets too deep so if someone's
incompatible with you
rejection will happen no matter what it
can either happen right away
or way down the road so opt for honest
communication
and quick rejection this is probably the
most unfun
unflattering social interaction advice
of all time hey it's better ideas here
here's how to get rejected nine times
out of ten so this last
bit of advice is all about demographics
and i picked up this bit of information
from models by mark manson
which is actually a book about dating
and relationships and stuff like that
but
this honestly applies to friendships or
any kind of
relationship that you want to enter into
so a lot of people complain that they
can't meet anyone like them you know
they're a special little snowflake they
have their own little interests and
hobbies maybe they have some
weird hobbies and interests and pretty
strange opinions
and they lament because they can never
find their tribe their people you know
people who think
exactly like them people they can just
hit it off with and have a great time
they can spew all their
bizarre opinions about whatever
together but people get sad because they
can't find people who get them
well a lot of people look in the most
general places
the most general public venues of all
time
for their soulmate their best friend
they're not actually
evaluating what interests they have what
values they hold
and going to the places where those
people exist you know you want to
increase your chances of finding people
that you connect with
that's just basic demographics
statistics come on
you know if you're religious start
actually going to that church
young adults group that you've been
avoiding you know there are a lot of
people who think like you
in that group you know if you're into
sports you're really athletic
then join an intramural or communal
sports team
start to get involved with the
extracurricular events and the little
optional group meetups and stuff like
that go where your people are there are
people who share your hobbies and your
passions
go there but sometimes you might not
have a crazy proficiency
in every single one of your hobbies so
you're afraid that if you go to one of
those group meetups like a photography
club
everyone's gonna laugh at you because
you suck you know you're not good at all
you should probably put down the camera
and never take a picture again
but luckily if you use today's video
sponsor skillshare that'll never happen
to you
skillshare is an online learning
community with
thousands of classes covering dozens of
topics
everything from photography to
cinematography to cooking to coding
even how to hone your voice online with
nathaniel drew which is the class that
i've most recently taken
and it's honestly such a great class
especially for people who have been
dabbling with the idea of starting a
youtube channel or a blog
maybe you see some of your favorite
youtubers and you think to yourself
maybe i can do that well a great place
to start to give you the right tools and
mindset to be able to tackle that
obstacle
is nathaniel drew's class his class like
so many other classes on skillshare
are designed to be extremely practical
so whatever you learn on skillshare
you can easily apply it to your
real-life pursuits and it's
so affordable especially when you
compare it to in-person classes and
workshops
if you pay for the annual membership it
comes in at less than ten dollars a
month and skillshare is doing this
awesome thing where for a limited time
only
if you use my link in the description
below you click it
you get a free trial to skillshare
premium which means
right now if you click the link you can
check out nathaniel drew's class
for free as well as all the other
classes on skillshare
so make sure you take advantage of that
link learn something new
explore your creativity and as usual
have a great time
if you like this video make sure to hit
like because when you hit like
the algorithm blesses me and it shoves
my bald head
into other people's home pages helping
them out
potentially helping them make friends
and stuff and helps me out too so it's
kind of a win-win for everybody so if
you just hit that like
the world is a better place instantly if
you're lurking here and this is the
billionth time that you've seen my face
and you haven't hit subscribe yet
make sure to hit subscribe and hit the
bell icon so that you get notified when
i upload new content
we also have a facebook page an
instagram page a
subreddit and i just did a subreddit
reaction video on my second channel i
put the link in the
i'll put the link in the description so
you can check that out if you haven't
noticed already actually
the backdrop kind of looks like my old
place but i'm in my new place now
getting some stability there's another
video coming out like
less than a the a week from now
two weeks from now there's also lots of
activity on the second channel
uh coming up but there also has been a
little bit
before so if you need more content and
better ideas isn't enough and you want
to see me more go to the second channel
where there's more content
catch you next